[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on se
retrouve dans les jardins du château de
versailles à la découverte d'une
nouvelle application les lapins crétins
à versailles elle a été créée par
ubisoft et dans un objectif faire
découvrir le jardin à toute la famille
alors on y va
[Musique]
la première mission commence dès le
parterre d'eau objectif repousser
l'invasion en montgolfière des lapins
contre le château une fois la mission
réussie on apprend que ce parterre
accueilla le premier vol habité en
ballon de l'histoire en 10min jeu basé
sur de la réalité augmentée il est
possible de découvrir les jardins ainsi
que leur histoire
par ailleurs en réalisant de bons scores
vous débloquerez des éléments
cosmétiques pour habiller votre lapin
comme à la cour du roi soleil
alors nous nous retrouvons avec paul
schene directeur adjoint de la
communication du château de versailles
bonjour bonjour pouvez-vous on peut nous
expliquer comment est née cette
application
pour quelles raisons avez vous mis en
place cette application lapins crétins à
versailles
ça fait presque un an qu'on travaille
sur ce projet et c'est vrai que pour
nous ça tout de versailles c'était très
important de concevoir de proposer un
produit une offre culturelle qui puisse
s'adresser à tous les publics et y
compris aux plus jeunes publics et aux
familles qui sont nombreux à venir à
versailles toute l'année et l'objectif
c'était aussi de mettre un peu de gaming
c'est quelque chose d'important toutes
ses mécaniques de jeu elles sont
importantes aujourd'hui dans la vie des
publics et donc de proposer un contenu
qui soit à la fois ludiques et
culturelles on apprend plein de choses
lors de sa visite au château de
versailles est donc déjà été produit par
ubisoft
comment comment est-ce que ça s'est mis
en place en effet ce jeu a été réalisée
dans le cadre d'un partenariat entre
ubisoft et le château de versailles et
c'était à la fois la volonté d'ubisoft
de travailler avec un site reconnu
mondialement comme le château de
versailles et la volonté du château de
versailles de proposer et de bénéficier
de l'expertisé en termes de gaming de
jeux vidéo d'ubisoft et j'imagine que
ubisoft a dû venir sur place wii ubisoft
est venu à plusieurs reprises dans les
jardins du château de versailles pour
préparer ce jeu réalisé en cas d'un
mécénat de compétences d'ubisoft pour le
château de versailles donc bien sûr il
ya un petit jeu de labyrinthe
hydraulique
qui se passe au niveau de la fontaine de
la tonne que vous pouvez observer ici il
ya également un peu au niveau de
l'orangerie il ya également des
mécaniques de jeu avec des topiaires ou
des mécaniques de jeu avec les fontaines
du bosquet du théâtre d'auch et bien
merci beaucoup pour cet entretien nous
nous continuons tout de suite notre
aventure dans les jardins du château
alors suivez nous
les lapins crétins à versailles est
disponible gratuitement sur toutes les
plateformes mobiles tels qu apple store
et google claire et accessible dans 5
langues différentes
comptez environ une heure et demie le
temps de déambuler et finir les
activités pour terminer le jeu
bon ben voila je ne trouve au bosquet du
théâtre d'auch et j'ai fini le dernier
mini jeux je me suis bien amusé et j'ai
appris plusieurs anecdotes sur les
jardins par contre comme vous allez le
voir le look du la pente c'est vraiment
pas ça
[Musique]